herr präsident meine damen und herren
haben sie den namen mahmud al zein schon
mal gehört das ist der chef eines der
größten kriminellen clans die in
deutschland ganze stadtteile beherrschen
schutzgeld erpressen die rauben und
schwere gewalt verfügen viele bürger
fragen sich warum haben wir solche
gangster bei uns denn dieser mahmud als
sein so konnte man jüngst in der presse
lesen hatte schon vor 31 jahren den
ersten abschiebe bescheid im briefkasten
war jahrzehntelang vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtig er wurde aber nie
abgeschoben die hunderttausend andere
auch nicht
und seit 31 jahren terrorisiert er die
deutsche bevölkerung wer hat in diesen
30 jahren regiert cdu/csu/fdp linke
grüne bund und ländern haben sie regiert
was wir hier sehen ist ein total
versagen sämtlicher altparteien ohne
ausnahme meine damen und herren aber
immerhin eines nehmen sie ja eines
lebens sie waren das sinken ihre
umfragewerte und vor jeder wichtigen
wahl schaffen sie neue gesetze gehören
sich dann so an als würden sie abhilfe
schaffen wie 2017 vor der bundestagswahl
da überschlug sich die merkel-regierung
weil die afg vor dem einzug in den
bundestag stand erst gelobte die
kanzlerin
das wichtigste sei jetzt wörtlich
rückführung rückführung und nochmals
rückführung dann verspricht zu den
deutschen wörtlich eine nationale
anstrengung für abschiebungen und
schließlich kurz vor der bundestagswahl
dann das neue gesetz 2007 gesetz zur
besseren durchsetzung der
ausreisepflicht drittes in kraft und was
ist das ergebnis all dieser
versprechungen all dieser ankündigung
gesetze gab es mehr abschiebung keine
einzige im gegenteil es wurden weniger
abgeschoben meine damen und herren
schlimmer noch als die asyl teuscher
sind die wahl teuscher die einer
schleichen sich asyl
die anderen hohe politische ämter und
heute kurz vor den entscheidenden
landtagswahlen im osten heißt die
regierung das sogenannte geordnete
rückkehr gesetz durchs parlament wieder
ein katalog hohler ankündigung in neues
gesetz verspricht wer den pass wegwirft
um über seine herkunft zu täuschen müsse
jetzt kooperieren beide schaffen neuer
dokumente aber fakt ist jeder migrant
muss los ein zettel unterschreiben er
habe sich um papiere bemüht belegen muss
er das mich kontrollieren tut das
niemand es reicht die bloße unterschrift
und alle bleiben da über diese naivität
lachen hunderttausende asyl teuscher in
aller welt sich kaputt damit muss
schluss sein
das gesetz verspricht auch eine
wiedereinreise sperre für intensivtäter
wie soll das gehen würde einer wie als
ein jetzt abgeschoben würde das klappen
er könnte doch jederzeit wieder rein
die grenze sind noch offen sie
kontrollieren doch nicht 15.000 kommen
jeden monat neu rein die hälfte ohne
pass bringt also gar nichts ihr gesetz
verspricht weiter der migranten vor
abschiebung warnt würde bestraft
fakt ist alle links grün
flüchtlingshelfer die vor einer
abschiebung waren sollen straffrei
bleiben ihr gesetz für angeblich
geordneten rückkehr ist eine doppel lüge
es schafft wieder ordnung noch rückkehr
aber die wähler merken dass die wähler
merken dass das sie unaufrichtig sind
und so die abschiebung die richtige
antwort für asyl teuscher ist ist abwahl
die richtige antwort für war teuscher
die sachsen die brandenburger und die
thüringer werden sie das schon in
wenigen wochen bei den landtagswahlen
merken lassen und das nicht zu knapp
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]